one of the first applications
of that we showed in the paper was to
crack uh text-based captchas what are
captures by the way
yeah by the way one of the most awesome
like the people don't use this term
anymore it's human computation i think
uh i love this term the guy who created
captchas
i think came up with this term yeah i
love it anyway uh
yeah uh what what are captures so
captchas are those strings that you fill
in
uh when you're you know when if you're
opening a new account in google
they show you a picture you know usually
it used to be
a set of garbage letters uh that you
have to kind of
uh figure out what what what is that
string of characters and type in
and the reason cap just exists is
because
you know google or twitter
do not want automatic creation of
accounts you can use
a computer to create millions of
accounts uh
and use that for in nefarious purposes
uh so you want to make sure that to the
extent possible
the interaction that your their system
is having
is with a human so it's a it's called a
human interaction
proof a captcha is a human interaction
proof um
so so this is a captchas are by design
things that are easy for humans to solve
but hard for computers it's hard for
robots
yeah so and text-based captchas
where was the one which is prevalent and
around 2014
because at that time text-based based
captchas were
hard for computers to crack even now
they
are actually in the sense of an
arbitrary text-based capture
will be unsolvable even now but with the
techniques that we have developed it can
be
you know you can quickly develop a
mechanism that solves
the captcha they've probably gotten a
lot harder too the people
that have been getting clever and clever
generating these text characters yeah
right so okay so that was one of the
things you've tested
on is these kinds of captures in 2014 15
got that kind of stuff right so what uh
what i mean
why by the way why captchas yeah yeah
even now i would say captcha is a very
very good challenge problem
uh if you want to understand how human
perception works and if you want to
build
uh systems that work like the human
brain
and i wouldn't say captcha is a solved
problem we have cracked the fundamental
defense of captures
but it is not solved in the way that
humans solve
it so i can give an example i can
um take a five-year-old child who has
just learned characters
and show them any new capture that we
create
they will be able to solve it uh i can
show you
pretty much any new capture from any new
website
you'll be able to solve it without
getting any training examples
from that particular style of captcha
you're assuming i'm human yeah yes
yeah that's right so if you are human
and
if you otherwise i will be able to
figure that out using this one
but uh so this whole podcast is just a
touring test
a long touring test anyway i'm sorry so
yeah
so human humans can figure it out with
very few examples
or no training examples like no training
examples from that particular style of
capture
and and so you can you know so uh even
now this is
unreachable for of the current deep
learning system so
basically there is no i don't think a
system exists where you can basically
say
train on whatever you want and then now
say hey i will show you a new captcha
which i did not show you in
in the in the training setup will the
system be able to solve it
still doesn't exist so that is the magic
of human perception yeah and
doug have starter uh put this uh very
beautifully in
one of his uh talks the the central
problem
in ai is what is the letter a
if you can if you can build a system
that reliably
can detect all the variations of the
letter a you don't even need to go to
the
the b and the c yeah you don't even know
the b and the c or the strings of
characters
and uh so that that is the spirit at
which you know with which we
uh tackle that what does it mean by that
i mean is it uh
like without training examples try to
figure out
the fundamental uh elements that make
up the letter a in all of its forms
in all of its forms it can be a can be
made with two humans standing leaning
against each other holding the hands
yeah
and uh it can be made of leaves it can
be yeah you might have to understand
uh everything about this world in order
to understand letter a
yeah exactly so it's common sense
reasoning essentially yeah
right so so to finally to really solve
finally to say that you have solved
captcha
uh you have to solve the whole problem
yeah okay so what how does uh this kind
of
the rcn architecture help us to get a do
a better job with that kind of yeah
so uh as i mentioned one of the
important things was
being able to do inference being able to
dynamically do in french
can you can you uh can you uh clarify
what you mean
because you say like neural networks
don't do inference yeah so what do you
mean by inference in this context then
so
okay so in captures what they do to
confuse people
is to make these characters crowd
together
yes okay and when you make the
characters crowd together
what happens is that you will now start
seeing combinations of characters as
some other new character or or an
existing character so you would
you would put an r and n together it
will start looking like an
m uh and and so locally they are you
know
there is very strong evidence for it
being
uh some uh incorrect character
but globally the only explanation that
fits together
is something that is different from what
you can find locally
yes so so so this is inference you are
basically taking
uh local evidence and putting it in the
global context
and often coming to a conclusion locally
which is
conflicting with the local information
so actually so
you mean inference like uh in the way
it's used
when you talk about reasoning for
example uh as opposed to like
inference which is this when you know
with artificial neural networks which is
a single pass to the network
okay so like you you're basically doing
some basic forms of reasoning
like integration of like uh how local
things fit into the the global picture
and and things like explaining away
coming into this one because
you are you are uh explaining that piece
of evidence
uh as something else uh because globally
that's the only thing that makes sense
um so now uh you
can amortize this inference by
you know in a neural network if you want
to do this what you you can
you can brute force it you can just show
it all combinations of things
that you want to you want to your
reasoning to work over
and you can you know like just train the
help out of that neural network
and it will look like it is doing uh you
know influence on the fly but it is it
is
really just doing amortized inference it
is because you
you have shown it a lot of these
combinations during training time
um so what you want to do is be able to
do dynamic inference rather than just
being able to show all those
combinations in the training time and
that's something we emphasized in the
model
what does it mean dynamic in france is
that that has to do with the feedback
thing yes like what what is dynamic i
i'm trying to visualize what dynamic
inference would be in this case
like what is it doing with the input
it's showing the input the first time
yeah and is it's like what's changing
over temporarily
over to what's the dynamics of this
inference process so so you can think of
it as
you have um at the top of the model the
characters that you
are trained on yeah they are the causes
they you are trying to
explain the pixels using the characters
as the causes the you know the
characters are the things that cost the
pixels
yeah so there's this causality thing so
the reason you mentioned
causality i guess is because there's a
temporal aspect of this whole thing
in this particular case the temporal
aspect is not important it is more like
when if if i turn the character on
the the pixels will turn on yeah it will
be after this a little bit but
okay yeah so that is the causality in
the sense of like a logic causality like
hence inference okay the dynamics is
that
uh even though locally it will look like
okay this is an a
and and locally just when i look at just
that patch of the image
it looks like an a but when i look at it
in the context of all the other courses
it might not you know aim is not
something that makes sense so that is
something we have to kind of
you know recursively figure out yeah so
okay so
and uh this thing performed pretty well
on the captchas correct
and um i mean is there some kind of
interesting intuition you can provide
why did well
like what did it look like is there
visualizations that could be human
interpretable to us humans
yes yeah so the good thing about the
model is that it is
extremely um so it is not just doing a
classification right it is it is it is
it is providing a full explanation for
the scene so when when it
when it um operates on a scene
it is coming at back and saying look
this is the part
is the a and these are the pixels that
turned on
uh these are the pixels in the input
that tells makes me think that
it is an a and also these are the
portions i hallucinated
it you know it it provides a complete
explanation of that form and
then again these are the contours these
are this is the interior
and this is in front of this other
object so
that that's the kind of um explanation
it uh
the the inference network provides so so
that
that is useful and interpretable um
and uh um then the kind of errors
it makes are also i don't want to
um read too much into it but the kind of
errors the network makes are
uh very similar to the kinds of errors
humans would make
in a similar situation so there's
something about the structure that's
uh feels reminiscent of the way humans
uh visual
system works well i mean
uh how hard-coded is this to the capture
problem
this idea uh not really hardcoded
because it's the
assumptions as i mentioned are general
right it is more
um and and those themselves can be
applied in many
situations which are natural signals um
so it's it's the foreground versus
background factorization
and the factorization of the surfaces
versus the contours
so these are all generally applicable
assumptions in our vision
so why why capture
why attack the capture problem which is
quite unique in the computer vision
context versus like the traditional
benchmarks
of imagenet and all those kinds of image
classification or even segmentation
tests all that kind of stuff
do you feel like that's uh i mean what
what's your thinking about those kinds
of benchmarks
in um in this in this context i mean
those benchmarks are useful
for deep learning kind of algorithms
where you
you know so the settings uh that deep
learning works in
are here is my huge training set
and here is my test set so the the
training set is
almost uh you know 100 x 1000 x bigger
than
uh the test set in many many cases
uh what we wanted to do was invert that
the training set is way smaller than the
the test set yes uh and uh uh
and you know uh captcha is a problem
that is by definition
hard for computers and it has these good
properties
of strong generalization strong out
of training distribution generalization
if you are interested in studying that
and putting uh having your model have
that property
then it's a it's a good data set to
tackle so is there
have you attempted to which i think i
believe there's quite a growing
body of work on looking at mnist and
imagenet
without training so it's like taking
like the basic challenge is
how what tiny fraction of the training
set can we take in order to do
a reasonable job of the classification
task
of have you explored that angle in these
classic benchmarks yes so so we did do
mnist so
um you know so it's not just capture we
uh so there was
uh also uh uh versions of
multiple versions of mnist including the
the standard version
which where we inverted the problem
which is basically saying rather than
train on 60 000
uh training data uh you know how uh
quickly can you get uh to high level
accuracy with very little training data
is there some performance do you
remember like how well
how well did it do how many examples did
he need
yeah i i you know i remember that it was
you know uh on the order of uh
tens or hundreds of examples to get into
uh 95
accuracy and it was it was definitely
better than the systems other systems
out there
at that time at that time yeah yeah
they're really pushing i think that's a
really
interesting space actually uh i think
there's an actual name for mnist
that uh like there's different names the
different sizes of training sets
i mean people are like attacking this
problem i think it's super interesting
yeah
it's funny how like that mnist will
probably
be with us all the way to agi yes
it's the data set that just sticks by it
is it's a clean
simple uh data set to uh
to study the fundamentals of learning
with just like captures it's interesting
not enough people i don't know maybe you
can correct me but i feel like captures
don't show up
as often in papers as they probably
should that's correct yeah because
you know um usually these things have a
momentum
uh you know once once uh something gets
established
as a standard benchmark yeah there is a
there is a
uh there is a dynamics of uh how
graduate students operate and how
the academ academy system works that uh
pushes people to track that uh benchmark
so yeah
yeah so nobody wants to think outside
the box
okay
you